Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube là Excel bài số 6
các hành xử lý chuỗi tiếp theo bắt đầu
vào bài học số 6 cùng giải đáp và lúc
trước là bài số 5 ở đây mình có kết quả
học tập của năm 2002 ở đây có các trường
thông tin là số thứ tự họ tên điểm trung
bình để đạo đức Hoàng cột ghi chú câu
hỏi điền vào cuộc ghi chú theo tiêu
chuẩn sau những học sinh có đạo đức tốt
có điểm trung bình từ 4 trở lên hoặc
những học sinh có đạo đức trung bình có
điểm trung bình từ 5 trở lên Ghi là lên
lớp còn lại thì đi lạ ở lại lớp thì như
còn ghét ở đây mình có cái điện nếu như
đã rất tốt và có điểm trung bình từ 4
trở lên thì là lên lớp sau đấy là thẻ
hoặc những học sinh mà có đạo đức trung
bình và có điểm trung bình từ 5 trở lên
thì là lên lớp đúng ạ thì như vậy cái
điều kiện nước ở đây
Anh tên là cái hoặc thỏa mãn cái hiện
thỏa mãn điều kiện này đã lúc tốt và
trung bình từ 4 đây còn trường hợp Ngược
lại nếu nhưng mà học sinh có đã đức
trung bình và điểm trung bình từ 5 trở
lên thì là đến lớp đúng thì ở đây mình
sẽ dùng cái ngon nhá các bạn sẽ bàn về
kho của mở ngoặc thì cái trường hợp đầu
tiên là lên nước là gì đã rất tốt và
điểm trung bình từ 4 trở lên thì mình sẽ
dùng cái hạ men cũng ạ hàm em của mở
ngoặc đầu tiên là đã rất tôn gọi các bạn
sẽ thích vào cái ô Đạo Đức ở đây là all
4 bàn diện các bạn màu và kéo ra các bạn
bằng là tốt đúng ạ Các bạn đâu có khép
lại phải có điểm trung bình từ 4 trở lên
là điểm trung bình chính là cái ô ô C4 ở
đây này mà gì ạ lớn bằng 4 trở lên đúng
không phải là các bạn sẽ ghi là lớn hơn
hoặc bằng 4 lại các bạn xem đóng ngoặc
lại để xong các men đấy Bây giờ là phải
nhắc cái phải là cho cái điều kiện hoặc
ngoài này nếu như mà không thỏa mãn các
em này thì còn một cái trường hợp viêm
nước khác là diện là đã lúc trung bình
và ạ và cái
xe điện trung bình phải lớn hơn năm trở
lên để thì các bạn lạnh dùng em tiếp các
bạn mở ngoặc nhá biểu thức luôn thích
thứ nhất là gì ạ Là cái đạo đức Ở đây
còn chính ở đây nó đang vướng với công
thức rồi các bạn không thích được vào
cái ô nên muốn ở đây thì các bạn gọi
trực tiếp luôn là gì D4 Bằng đấy ạ bằng
mở ngoặc ra là trưng bình thì lại gọi
cho nó ngoặc kép lại phẩy cái nữa xích
lô gic thứ hai của các hàm e là gì ạ Nếu
như mà đã lúc Trung bình thì cái điểm
trung bình là phải từ 5 trở lên đúng
không điểm trung bình là cái ôm C4 đây
để các bạn không thích điều ở đây đúng
không Thì họ sẽ gọi cho kết là C4 hoặc
các bạn thích bạn cái ô gì cả các bạn
thích và cái ôm bốn các bạn ấn mũi tên
Sang phải này thì nó sẽ sang cái ô C4
này đây quá mà dị ạ lớn hơn hoặc bằng
Nam để gọi sẽ đóng ngoặc lại để xong cái
Hà mint tức là xong cái biểu thức lôgic
thứ hai của cái hào lại bây giờ có thật
đóng hoặc lại để xong cái Hà moi nhá Đấy
nếu như mà thỏa mãn cái được Ức Ngày Đó
Có Em tơ đi đấy Đây là
các bạn này chưa từng Tại vì đã nước
chúng mình mà điển lại có 4 thôi đúng
không Bây giờ họ sẽ tính lúc vào đây lại
như các bạn nào là phô hội là bạn ấy sẽ
duyệt và ở lại lớp đó các bạn xem này
bạn ấy là cô mặc dù đã rất tốt nhưng mà
cái điện trung bình của bạn ấy có 3 điểm
thôi không ạ Bạn ấy là khô đấy bạn này
thì vừa đỡ chúng mình vừa điểm ba cho
nên bạn bè thôi như vậy Ở đây mình đã
xong cái biểu thức lôgic đề rồi nhá Bây
giờ mình sẽ dùng cái Hà mít này các bạn
đút vào đây để qua sử công thức nhé Thì
trước cái nào lại con sẽ có một câu lệnh
thực hiện ít khi các bạn mở ngoặc Nếu
như mà thỏa mãn cái Hà Nho này thì dễ có
bạn xuống cuối này còn phải các bạn mở
két ra là điện lên lớp đã gọi cho nó
ngoác em ạ Phải nếu như ngược lại rất là
không thỏa mãn cả hai cái điều kiện này
đúng không ạ thì họ sẽ ghi là điện hỏi
là lớp à
Dù sao thì đóng ngoặc kép tại họ phấn
đấu ngoặc đơn lại để xong là ít người
tao em tơ để như vậy bạn lại là ở lại
lớp đúng không ạ Đấy bạn thấy có 3 bạn ở
lại lớp 11 này ai ba còn lại là lên lớp
hết bây giờ mình kiểm tra xem nhé ví dụ
bạn này là trung bình nhưng mà điểm ở
đây là 6 này đấy bạn lại trung bình
những điểm là chín là lên nước đấy có
hai bạn Trung Bình mà lên nước nhé Còn
lại tốt nhá tốt mà ở đây là 4 điểm là
nước bây giờ ví dụ chẳng hạn như bạn này
đã nước chúng mình mà điểm ở đây là gì
biển nó năm thì bạn này sẽ là nước ai
gọi nhá Bây giờ mình sẽ ngược lại là bốn
đi thì bạn lại gọi lại lớp bố nhưng mà
lớn nhưng mà dễ đã rất là tốt tại các
bạn thấy thì nó lại là lên lớp như vậy
công thức của mình đúng rồi nhá Ok như
vậy là mình đã trả lời xong câu hỏi của
bài tập số 5 bây giờ mình sẽ sang cái
bài tập số 6 nhé á
Ừ Ok mình sẽ vào bảng số 6 các bạn chú ý
mình sẽ để cái phần link tải file thực
hành trong phần mô tả thế giới video thì
tốt nhất là các bạn tải về các bạn vừa
theo dõi và thực hành cùng mình nhé nếu
như bạn nạp không biết cách tải về thì
các bạn có thể theo dõi Cái bài đầu tiên
thì trong bài đó mình đã hướng dẫn chi
tiết cách tải về nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ mở
cái file này lên hôm nay mình sẽ học khá
là nhiều hàng toàn là các hành xử lý
chuỗi nhé Ở đây giả sử diện mình có cái
chìa họ tên các bạn thấy không họ tên
này nó thừa rất là nhiều dấu cách thì
đầu tiên mình sẽ giới thiệu với các bạn
cái hàng chim để cậu sẽ bằng này chim
đoạn sẽ ăn tát nhá Thì cái thành phần
của cái hàng chim này là cái ô mà các
bạn cần gọn này các bạn sẽ thích bà cái
Omega này các bạn enter đấy thì cái hàng
chim này nó làm việc gì nó sẽ gọt tất cả
những cái khoảng trống đằng sau và cây
đặt trước đi còn những cái khoảng trống
mà ở giữa hai cái từ này ạ thì nó chỉ
bớt lại một thôi để gọi này chứ ở đây
số còn lại là Nguyễn Văn bản rất là đẹp
bây giờ con sẽ thích lúc nhá gái gọi này
chứ toàn bộ các cái họ tên ở đây nó đã
được viện nó sẽ gọt đi cái khoảng trống
thừa Tiếp theo là cái Hà proper cái hàng
proper nó sẽ làm việc gì nó sẽ viết hoa
tất cả những cái ký tự đầu tiên của các
chuỗi này còn rất thích và cái ô D3 này
để gọi nhiều công thức nhé bằng proper
để các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống khi mà cái
chữ rapper này nó được tô đậm nha các
bạn sẽ tắt thì cái thành phần của cái Hà
proper là gì Là cái chuỗi và sau khi các
bạn gọi này chính ngại oshiba đấy Các
enter đây còn thấy chứ như vậy toàn bộ
các cái chữ ở đây thì Cái chữ đầu đã
được viết hoa đúng không các chữ sao là
vợ sẽ biết thường hết bây giờ giả sử cái
chữ bài 3 này nhá và cái chữ N cuối cùng
mình Viết hoa đi để gọi enter đây thì
cái hạt rapper này nó sẽ chuyển được cái
chữ thường hết chỉ có cái ký tự đầu tiên
của mỗi từ ở đây sẽ biết hoa thôi Bây
giờ còn thích nó vào đây hãy gọi thế đó
hãy đẹp rồi ạ ạ
thì mình sẽ giới thiệu với các bạn cách
hợp Al cái Hà hấp ơi này nó sẽ làm việc
gì đó sẽ viết hoa toàn bộ cây chuối và
các bạn chọn để có sắc bằng nhà Popper
các bạn có thể tắt nhá Thì cái thành
phần của cái hopper lại là các chuỗi và
các bạn cần viết hoa đúng không ạ Các
Bạn xuất tinh mà cái chú ếch mà sau khi
bạn đã gọi đây này chính là cái oc3 các
bạn enter để gọi lại chứ như vậy toàn bộ
cái Nguyễn Văn bản ở đây nó đã được viết
hoa hết bây giờ có thích bộ vào đây để
gọi theo Khá là đẹp ạ Tiếp theo là cái
hàm lơ cách hành lâu ơi này nó ngược với
cảm aupair tức là diệt toàn bộ các chuỗi
và các bạn chọn nó sẽ chuyển về kí tự
thường để gọi cho bằng bằng lâu để gọi
tắt nhá Thì cái thành phần của khách
hàng Noel là cái chuối mà các bạn tách
đúng không Mình sẽ tích và toc 3 Tức là
cái chuối mà sau khi mình gọt dữ liệu là
các loại enter để gọi thấy như vậy toàn
bộ cái ký tự ở đây nó sẽ chuyển về cái
chữ thường hết các bạn anh Dũng vào đây
khá là hay ạ Tiếp theo là cái hàm len
nhá cái hàm len này khách hàng và tính
cái độ
đăng ký tự không ạ Các bạn sẽ bằng bằng
len cái gọi là mũi tên xuống và các bạn
tắt nhá Thì cái thành phần của cái thằng
len này là việc là cái ô mà các bạn cần
cần đếm số ký tự đúng không Ví dụ tích
và cái Omega 3 này đi Mình xem là cái
Omega này là bao nhiêu kí tự các loại
enter đấy Cái Omega này là tất cả 20 ký
tự cơ Bây giờ mình xem cái oc3 này là
bao nhiêu ký tự nhé thì các bạn sẽ thích
đúng và cái Ova 3 này để có sửa công
thức này thì các bạn thay b bằng c Tức
là mình sẽ đến trong oc3 này là bao
nhiêu kí tự các bạn em từ đấy nó sẽ là
14 tích cực thì như vậy cái Hàn chim và
sau khi nó đã gọt cái B3 thì nó sẽ gọt
bao nhiêu từ 20 ký tự xuống còn thiện
còn 14 ký tự như vậy là 6 ký tự đã bị
gọi đi nó bao gồm điện Các bạn chú ý là
bao gồm một số ký tự ở bên trái à tức là
trước cái chuyên viên ban à và một số ký
tự ở đây nó bị thừa cái khoảng trống đây
như vậy nó ra khoảng 6 thứ tự quá Bây
giờ họ sẽ bước vào đây đấy Bạn thấy là
cái cột C này nó sẽ là được bao nhiêu ký
tự nhé
Ừ ok tiếp theo mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn
một số cách hành xử lý chuỗi khác nha
đầu tiên là cái hàm f khách hàng mét là
Thiện nó sẽ lấy trái chà sửa đây mình có
cái ô là gái xem nhé bây giờ mình muốn
Tách cái chữ gà cho biết chỗ này thì
mình làm như thế nào các bạn sẽ bằng
bằng led các bạn có thể tương tác nhá
thì thành phần đầu tiên của các hạt mát
là cái chuỗi và các bạn cần tắt đúng
không Mình sẽ thích và Cái ô thì ob10 ở
đây đấy phải thành phần thứ hai là số ký
tự mà các bạn cần trách đúng không ở đây
Nếu như các bạn muốn lấy cái chữ gà này
ra thì có sẽ lấy hai thứ tự đúng chữ g
và sự à Đây này tại Gọi sẽ hay Họ sẽ
đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong các em nhắc
các bạn enter đấy thì như vậy Ở đây mình
đã lấy được cái chữ gà đây rồi Giả sử
bây giờ mình muốn lấy cái chữ cái Excel
thì mình làm như thế nào thì gọi chú
nhắc cái chữ gà là hai thứ tự đúng không
cái chữ Excel là 5 ký tự là 7 thứ tự và
một cái khoảng trống ở đây là cái dấu
cách là 8 ký tự luôn các bạn tính lúc
vào Cái ô này để con sữa nhá thì các bạn
chỉ cần thay số 2 bằng bằng số 8 vào đây
đâu để gặp em chơi à
chị sẽ lấy được gì ạ là cái chuỗi gái
xem tiếp theo là cái hàng like cái hàng
like này nó ngược với cách làm net hàng
Like nó sẽ lấy số ký tự ở bên phải cơ
đấy Bây giờ giả sử mình muốn Tách cái
xuống năm ở đây là 2020 thì mình làm như
thế nào các bạn sẽ bằng rồi các bạn sẽ
bằng cái hàng like thì các thành phần
đầu tiên của khách hàng Like là cái
chuỗi mà các bạn đơn Chạnh đúng không
chính là cái ôm 10 đây phải cái thành
phần tiếp theo của các hàng Like là cái
số ký tự mà các bạn cần trách đúng không
Bây giờ mình muốn lấy cái năm 2020 thì
các bạn sẽ là rẻ các bạn sẽ khách bốn
cái chữ ra đúng không các bạn sẽ đóng
ngoặc đơn lặng để xong cái hàng like các
bạn em tơ nhá Đấy thì như vậy mình đã
tách được ra đây là điện 2020 rồi nhá
hàng tiếp theo là cái hàng mét rồi cái
hàng mi đồ này nó sẽ là kết hợp của cái
hành ghép và like hay nói cách khác nó
là gì ạ Tách cái số ký tự ở giữa thì họ
sẽ bằng bằng cách hàng mi được các bạn
tắt nhá thì thành phần đầu tiên của
khách hàng mix đồ là diện là cái chuỗi
mà các bạn cần trách Đúng không các bạn
sẽ tích và cái ôm này à
lịch sử mình muốn Tách cái chữ Excel
trong cái chỗ này nhá Đợi thì mình làm
như thế nào thì phải lại các thành phần
thứ hai của khách hàng biết đổ Đây là
cái vị trí đầu tiên mà các bạn thân
trách đúng không Thì nếu như các bạn
muốn Tách cái chữ Excel thì các bạn phải
xem cái vị trí đầu tiên của cái chữ em à
Thì bạn đến nha Cái chữ gà này là hai
thứ tự cái dấu cách là các ký tự thứ 3
và cái chữ E là cái thứ tư đúng không
như vậy sẽ là ký tự bắt đầu là ký tự thứ
tư phải cái thành phần tiếp theo của các
hãng mix đồ là số ký tự mà các bạn thần
trách thì ở đây mình cần tách cái chữ
Excel đúng không Thì cái số kích thước
của mình là đẹp là năm thứ tự chữ Excel
là năm thứ tự mà thì họ sẽ biệt giữa năm
rồi Đây có xem đóng ngoặc đơn lại để
song ca ăn ý đồ khác enter đây Thì như
vậy là mình đã tách được cái chữ Excel
đó bây giờ xử mình muốn Tách cái số 2020
mà mình dùng cái hàng mix đồ thì mình
làm như thế nào thì Cạn Thúy Nga Cái chữ
gà là hai này Excel là năm là 7 cái dấu
cách này là 8kg cách lên chín và cái số
2 đầu tiên là số 10 đúng không là thứ 11
em chưa vào đây họ sửa để con tiếp 24
Tức là cái vị trí bắt đầu bằng vị trí
thứ 10 đúng không và năm 2020 là bốn
trật tự đấy các bạn sẽ thích vào đây các
bạn sẽ thay số 5 số 4 là các enter lại
thì nó sẽ lấy được năm 2020 bây giờ xử
mình muốn Tách cái chữ cái xem nhá Mình
dùng cái hàng ít đồ các bạn thích bước
vào đây thì rẽ các vị trí bắt đầu thì
chắc chắn là vị trí thứ nhất rồi đó mình
sẽ xóa được không đi thì là vị trí đầu
tiên là số 1 luôn và các chị gái Excel
và cả cái dấu cách này là 8 ký tự luôn
sẽ thay số 4 bằng số 8 các bạn enter đấy
thì như vậy các bạn sẽ tách Được cái chị
gái Excel bây giờ quay lại nhắc mình
muốn Tách cái chữ Excel này ra tôi nhắc
cái nút vào đây thì đầu tiên là cái chữ
số 4 này đã bắt đầu đúng không Lấy số
thứ tự nhưng cần tách là năm các bạn
enter lại thì như vậy là mình đã anh
tiếp theo là gì Là cái hành vi Plus cái
hành vi quyết là địa là cái hành thay
thế nhé ok Bây giờ giả sử Mình muốn thay
cái chữ cái Excel bằng cái thẻ bằng cái
gà Gold 2020 thì mình làm như thế nào
các bạn sẽ bằng Harris này
ở Pháp nhé Thì các thành phần đầu tiên
của cái hàng biết là cái Ok thế là cái
chuỗi gốc ban đầu đúng không các bạn sẽ
tích và cái chuỗi gái Seo 2020 Đây có
phải là tiếp theo là gì ạ Cái sát number
Tức là cái vị trí bắt đầu cần thay đúng
không Thì mình cần phải cái chữ xe này
thì cái vị trí bắt đầu lên là vị trí thứ
tư đúng không phẩy tiếp theo là gì ạ Cái
số ký tự và các bạn cầnthanh ở đây là
cái chữ Excel là đăng ký tự đó là năm
lại phải tiếp theo là cái mũ Tết Tức là
mình sẽ thay thế bằng cái gì lại bằng
cái chuỗi mới nhá thì bạn sẽ móc kép ra
mình sẽ thay bằng cái chữ word đấy có
thể đóng ngoặc kép lại các bạn sẽ đóng
ngoặc đơn lại để song hành với biết các
bạn m đấy thì như vậy cái chuỗi gái
sur20 20 được thay thế bằng việc bằng
cái gà word hay không hay mưa lại nó khá
là hay Tiếp theo là cái hàng Red cái
hàng này là rẻ nó sẽ lặp lại cái chữa
trị tự đợi ví dụ cái chữ gã Excel 2020
này mình muốn lặp lại 10 lần thì mình là
như thế nào các bạn sẽ bằng gì ạ bằng
cái hàng Red lại cọ sơn
ở mũi tên xuống gọi khác nhé ví dụ mình
sẽ thay cái chỗ này lại phải mình sẽ
nhân lên ba lần thôi thì họ sẽ biển số 3
ở đây còn sự kiện đóng ngoặc đơn lại
khóc enter đấy thì như vậy chuỗi gái xe
2020 đã được lặp lại rẻ lặp lại 3 lần
bây giờ xử quá Muốn biết số 1 tỷ và bạn
điền nhanh ở đây Nhắc họ sẽ bằng điện
Các bạn xem bằng một này sau đó gọi Và
với cả diện và 9 số không có 1 tỷ thì
gọi sẽ bằng cái hàng khác để chọn xe gì
Các bạn ấn vào chữ xuống còn tát nhá thì
bạn không à cần phải đúng không đấy Gọi
sẽ gặp lại 9 lần đấy Gọi sẽ đóng ngoặc
đơn lại các em thơ ấy còn thấy chứ như
vậy Ở đây đã là cái số 1 tỉ rồi Rất là
hai ạ Đấy là cách ứng dụng để mình sẽ
dùng cái hẹp và bạn chú ý nhá các ký tự
và ở đây là cái nối chuỗi nhá Đợi thì
sau này mình sẽ hướng dẫn thêm về cái
này thì các bạn hiểu ở đây cái Và đây là
lối chuỗi lại nếu như bạn bỏ số một đi
các loại bỏ số 1 mà và đi nhá các bạn
enter Cậu đấy chứ như vậy Ở đây là dịa9
số không được gặp lại rồi Rất là hai em
ạ
nhà hàng Pha nhé Bây giờ giả sử Mình cần
tìm cái Excel trong Cái ô này thì mình
làm như thế nào các bạn sẽ bản thấy file
đấy thì đầu tiên là dễ cái file tex Tức
là cái chuỗi mà cậu cần tìm của họ sẽ mở
kẹp ra còn ghi chữ Excel các loại sân
đóng ngoặc kép bạn cần phải tiếp theo là
gì là mình cần tìm với chuỗi xe này
trong cái chỗ nào thì trong cái ô này
không ạ phẩy Tiếp theo là cái vị trí
mình cần tìm thì thông thường mình sẽ
tìm từ cái vị trí đầu tiên đúng không
thì các bạn sẽ điểm số 1 vào đây gọi cho
nó ngoác lại thì nếu như mà cái vị trí
mà các bạn bắt đầu tìm kiếm các bỏ rộng
ấy thì nó cũng tương đương là một thôi
nhá các bạn em từ đây thì cái kết quả nó
trả về bố lên đây là gì Là cái ký tự đầu
tiên mà nó tìm thấy cũng ạ Ở đây nó tìm
cái chữ Excel nhé Thì nó tìm thấy cái
chỗ này và nó sẽ tính là cái chữ em này
là cái vị trí bắt đầu mà nó tìm được
đúng không Thì làm cái gì thứ Tư bây giờ
xử mình tìm một cái chuối nó không có
nhá Ví dụ mình thay cái chữ xe bằng chữ
a a thẳng Thế nhá Để gọi m
anh không tìm thấy nó sẽ báo là ve lên
đã gọi thích đút vào đây còn chửi nhé
cái chữ mà chửi Excel Nếu như các bạn
biết thường ấy đợi thì nó sẽ cũng báo
lỗi ngay tại vì cái file đó sẽ phân biệt
chữ hoa và chữ thường đẩy cái chữ Excel
đây lớn các bạn mà viết cái chữ e đầu
tiên là chữ thường thì nó sẽ báo không
tìm thấy mình sẽ thành chữ hoa lại enter
thì nó sẽ trả về cái vị trí bắt đầu mà
nó tìm thấy Tiếp theo là cái làm search
cái hàm sát này thì nó như thế nào hạ
sốt này Thực ra nó giống hệt kèm file
nhưng mà diện nó sẽ không phân biệt chữ
hoa và chữ thường đấy trong trường hợp
mà các bạn không phân biệt chữ hoa và
chữ thường thì gọi lên dùng cái hạt mà
các bạn Nếu như các bạn tìm kiếm và phân
biệt thì bạn sẽ dùng cái file ở đây
thoại sang bằng nhá mình sẽ dùng cái hồ
sơ cho bạn xem sớm thì thành phần đầu
tiên của học suốt này làm gì ạ Cái chuỗi
các bạn cần tìm đúng không ở đây mình sẽ
mở kẹp ra các bạn sẽ ghi chữ Excel bây
giờ ví dụ mình ghi cái chữ Excel là chữ
thường nhé Không phải là chứ tức là chữ
e đầu tiên là chữ thức thường này không
lẽ ngoan đúng không phẩy
từ hôm nay đấy phải Nếu như các bạn biết
một ở đây cũng được mà các bạn bảo giống
cũng được thì nó sẽ hiểu là tìm từ vị
trí đầu tiên cậu enter đấy còn thấy như
vậy cái hành xét này sẽ không phân biệt
chữ hoa và chữ thường nhé Ok Bây giờ giả
sử cái vị trí mình bắt đầu tìm kiếm lại
không phải là vị trí đầu tiên mà vị trí
thứ năm đi chở nặng thế nhá thì gọi sẽ
trả về kết quả gì nó sẽ báo kết quả là
không tìm thấy này các bạn enter đấy nó
sẽ báo là Lossless Tại vì sao ạ Nó bắt
đầu tìm từ cái chữ X cơ đấy cái vị trí
thứ 5 này mà là từ vị trí x này có thì
từ cái vị trí ý đây này Nó sẽ không có
cái chữ treo là cả đúng không ạ Rồi
tương tự cái số 4 rồi Nhát nếu như các
vị trí cuối cùng mà còn phải ở đây Nếu
như vị trí các bạn cần tìm kiếm là vì đi
thứ sáu rồi hạnh á thì nó có báo lỗi
ngay đấy Cho nên nếu như cái vị trí bắt
đầu tìm kiếm các bạn quả rộng thì nó
hiểu là tìm từ các vị trí đầu tiên lại
Bây giờ mình bảo ông đi thì nó hiểu là
tìm từ cái vị trí đầu tiên tiếp theo là
khách hàng
anh cái ảnh shop ti ti này là Thiện nó
cũng là dùng để thay thế thôi nó giống
như cao huyết nhưng mà nó sẽ dùng khác
đi một tí để họ sẽ bằng đấy ạ Các bạn sẽ
bằng cái hòm sắt chim thì đầu tiên ý là
cách tức là gì ạ Cái ô gốc là ô ban đầu
đúng không là cái chuối này hạ thế Bây
giờ mình sẽ thay thế bằng cái gà word 20
20 nhá thì phải lại thì cái Attack là gì
Cái Attack mình sẽ thay cái chữ gì chữ
Excel các bạn nó khép lại phải bằng cái
gì bằng cái newtech ở đây Bạn mở kẹp ra
bạn cái gốc còn đóng khép lại đấy Các
thành phần cuối cùng là cái int number
nhé Thì là gì ạ Cái thành phần này là
tùy chọn nếu như mà dị ạ Các bạn bỏ rộng
thịt cứ thấy Excel Nó sẽ thay bằng bút
đúng ạ Còn nếu như mà các ạ thích chọn
rồi đấy thì lát nữa mình sẽ giải thích
cho bạn sau nhé Bây giờ mình cứ đóng
ngoặc đơn lại các em Thơ đấy gọi thấy
chứ Thì như vậy cái chữ Excel
ở Hàn Quốc Bây giờ có ít nước vào Cái ô
này mình sửa gì ạ bây giờ cái chữ Excel
mà lặp lại hai lần đi đấy các bạn ạ tư
nhá Thì như vậy Ở đây là gì đấy cảm thấy
chứ cứ tìm thấy cái chữ Excel thì nó sẽ
thay ngòi bút để gọi bởi ghế ta thì bạn
thấy ông Cái ô này là cứ tìm thấy Excel
thì nó sẽ thay ngòi bút đúng không Bây
giờ có tích lũy và công thức này còn sửa
nhé Thì cái thành phần cuối cùng của Đây
có phải là nếu như mà cái tham số cuối
cùng của cái hòm xuất huyết tiêu này mà
là số 2 kết số 2 này nghĩa là gì Tức là
cái chữ Excel thứ hai thì nó mới thay
thế thôi đúng không còn cái Excel đầu
tiên này nó sẽ không thay thế gọi em tơ
này cao thấy chưa thì cái ít sao đầu
tiên nó sẽ không thay thế vẫn giữ nguyên
và nó sẽ thay thế từ cái Excel thứ hai
thôi là nó sẽ đổi thành word lại đây là
cái is number là cái ý nghĩa của nó là
như vậy nhá lại nếu như bạn bên một đây
nó sẽ trả lời gì đấy thì nó chỉ thay cái
vị trí xem đầu tiên này thôi còn cái vị
trí xem thứ hai thì nó sẽ không thay thế
là có đi đổ vào đây ạ
các bạn bỏ giống nhá thì nó sẽ thay thế
toàn bộ cứ thấy Excel thì nó sẽ thay thế
của Word không ạ Cái hàng này thì mình
hay dùng hơn là cái hàng hết bởi vì cái
hành giết chết thì nó lại dùng diện nó
lại phải phụ thuộc và cái vị trí bắt đầu
rồi và đến ký tự cơ thì đôi chim nó thức
cảm hơn cái hành sắp xếp tim thì với
trường học của gà thì gà hay dùng cái
hành suốt kiếp yêu hơn Tiếp theo là cái
hàng Tết nhá cái hàng Tech nó sẽ dùng để
làm gì Nó sẽ thay đổi các định dạng đấy
bây giờ cạn Ví dụ nhé các bạn sẽ bằng
bằng Tech để gọi xe mở ngoặc ra cái
value Giả sử mình muốn say rượu mình
muốn cái số 0.9 nhá 0.95 đi Đấy mình
muốn thay cái 0.95 này về các bạn Phần
trăm đúng không Thì bạn Rịa các đầu tiên
là cái vali chính là cái số 0.95 cần
phải lại cái format nó mình sẽ thay về
phần trăm bốn con con sẽ mở ngoặc kép ra
bây giờ mình sẽ thay đổi về cái định
chạm Phần trăm đúng không thì các bạn
ghi cho mình là gì Thằng này chấm gì ạ
chấm Không không
về sau đó bạn để các thêm cái chữ phần
trăm và nữa các bạn đóng ngoặc kép ạ Đấy
cái này là gì Cái này là đổi định dạng
về phần trăm nhá các bạn về cái phần
tăng chấm công không thì sau này mình sẽ
giải thích cho bạn rõ hơn nhá thì trước
mắt các bạn biển thế này cho mình nhé
Hãy gọi em tơ đợi cảm thấy nhá như vậy
cái số 95 sẽ đổi về địa 95 phần trăm bây
giờ cái 0.95 mình sẽ thay bằng việc 0.75
trả lại nhé đây thì nó sẽ là 75 phần
trăm Tiếp theo là cái hàm value nhá có
chửi nha như cái Hằng live vừa xong ấy
là các bạn lấy 4 ký tự thì các bạn sẽ
tách được là năm 2020 nhưng mà cái số
2020 này không phải là số đâu mà nó là
tết đấy nếu nhưng mà là số ví dụ các bạn
Nhập lại 2020 nếu như là số thì nó sẽ
làm ở bên tay phải là cơ còn 20 20 màn
đón ở bên tay trái này là thích cơ không
phải là số đâu Thì bây giờ để chuyển cái
20 20 này về lại số thì các bạn sử dụng
cái hành vol nhé các bạn Bằng và Lưu các
bạn có thể Hiến pháp này thì cái thành
phần của cái hàng vali
tất cả các bạn cần chuyển về dạng số là
các diện tích vào đây các bạn enter đợi
thì nó sẽ chuyển về 20 20 Các bạn thấy
chứ 20 20 Lúc này nó đã nằm ở bên tay
phải này thì nó là số rồi nhá tiếp theo
là hẹp exact khách hàng này là diện nó
sẽ So sánh hai cái chữ kí tự đây ví dụ
bạn bằng này ít xác này các bạn có thể
tắt nhá Thì cái chuỗi đầu tiên ví dụ là
gì ạ là cái gái xe ở đây đúng không Đấy
phải mì so với cả diện mình sẽ so với
màu kẹp là gái xem họ sẽ đóng ngoặc kép
lại các bạn đó hoặc đơn lại các em tơ
nếu như nó bằng nhau thì nó sẽ trả lại
kết quả chung đúng không Bây giờ giả sử
Nếu như cái ô này mà mình lấy mình cái
Lấy 2 ký tự thôi nhá Đây thì hai cái ô
hiện cái chữ gà này này là Cái ô thì
oc10 với cả cái chữ cái xe nha con tích
nước vào đây lại cái oc10 là cái chữ gà
và cái chuỗi lái xem nó không bằng nhau
đúng không Thì nó sẽ trả lời quả khô bây
giờ ví dụ ở đây mình lấy lấy là 8 ký tự
nhé các bạn enter đấy thì như vậy
Ừ cái oc10 với cả cái chữ cái xe là bằng
nhau thì nó sẽ trả về kết quả là Chu ấy
có thể lấy lại hàng Nexus Tiếp theo là
cái Hàn tra nhá hàng chang là gì ạ Nó sẽ
gì à nó sẽ biểu diễn cách mạng cốt từ
cái số 1 đến 255 về cây dạng ký tự lấy
ví dụ các bạn bằng cha có hiến pháp nhé
tra ví dụ của 65 đi đó sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn
lại gọi enter thì cái số 65 ở đây bản
chất là gì nó sẽ biểu diễn bằng cái kính
chữa tức là cách ký tự a và các bạn hay
gọi cái mã code của nó là cái ngã sáu
năm cơ đấy gọn hiểu đơn giản là như vậy
nhé thì sau này mình sẽ nói một số ứng
dụng của cái hàng tra sau giống như cái
kiểu ký tự xuống dòng nhá thì nó lại là
cha 10 cơ để họ sẽ Bằng ví dụ các bạn gõ
trên gà đấy đấy ạ và này và là cái nối
chuỗi tra gì ạ quận mở ngoặc là số 10
này các bạn sẽ đóng mọc đơn lại sau đó
bạn và với cả diện và cái chữ Excel Gọi
chú ý nhất cái chữ Excel ở đây gọi phản
diện trong
anh khép đôi mắt Khép cái chân gà cũng
vậy nhé Phải gọi xe mở ngoặc kép ở đây
là đóng ngoặc kép ở ngoài cùng các bạn
phải có cái dấu bằng rồi đó enter lại
gọn kéo rộng ra đấy gọi thấy chứ như vậy
là rẻ cái tra 10 ở đây chính là cái ý tự
enter lại đây là một cách ứng dụng nhỏ
mình giới thiệu với các bạn nhé Tiếp
theo là cái hàm con tiết khách hàng có
kiếp này là cái Hà mà để diện mà để núi
ký tự với nhau bây giờ sửa Mình muốn kết
nối cái gái xe và cái 220 này lại nhá
thì họ sẽ bằng bằng cái khoét hết các
bạn hiểu chat nhá thì cây chuối ở đây là
gì gái xe này phải cái chuỗi thứ hai là
cái 2020 lại hoặc là dễ các bạn bỏ dép
ra các bạn thích kiểu cách này các bạn
đóng ngoặc kép lại phải cái tích Bà đây
chính là sẽ 5 20 20 để gọi enter đấy thì
nó sẽ nối lại đẹp nó sẽ gộp cái gái sau
này nó thêm cái dấu cách và nó nối với ô
2020 ở đó đấy ví dụ 20
em đổi thành điện 20 21 là thế nhé thế
Ngô này là gì gái Seo 2021 Ok như vậy là
mình đã xong cái bài hướng dẫn các hành
xử lý chỗ ở đây nhá Bây giờ mình sẽ xem
cái câu hỏi của bài tập ngày hôm nay đây
cái câu hỏi của anh Facebook rồi đấy ok
câu hỏi của mình là gì ở đây mình có
thông tin là tên đầy đủ nhá các bạn dùng
các cái Hàn và xử lý chuỗi các bạn sẽ
cách cho mình họ là gì và tên là gì nhá
đấy các bạn hãy comment cái câu trả lời
của bạn trong cái phần bình luận ở dưới
video nhá Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc
bài học ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các
bạn đã theo dõi các bạn nhé Đăng ký Kênh
để cập nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng
như chia sẻ để giúp mọi người của Ngọc
xem nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại à
ừ ừ